les canadiens aiment les cartes il
possède en moyenne neuf cartes fidélité
fidèles qui fidèles pourquoi en fait les
prends de fidélité c'est un prétexte
pour donner des données clients donc ce
qu'on veut c'est que le client
s'identifie à chaque semaine pour avoir
accès à ce qu'ils consomment et à quelle
fréquence bien chez nous pour par la
suite faire des offres plus ciblées dans
des gens laroche a participé à la
création du programme clube orange de
provigo sa compagnie a aussi développé
pour la saq le programme inspire et elle
collabore avec métro et moi donc c'est
un échange de bons procédés entre le
consommateur qui s'identifie qui donne
ces données est en revanche qu'on soit
en satin des bénéfices soir des points
soit des 1000 vous soit d'autres
éléments pour la remercier de sa
fidélité
c'est ce qu'on appelle du marketing
relationnel différent du marketing de
masse qui s'adresse à tout le monde
comme c'est le cas des circulaires le
professeur louis fabien et spécialiste
en gestion du service à la clientèle
on essaie de développer une relation
avec le client et à la longue
en récompensant fuir le client qui avait
compensé toujours encouragé les trois
principaux programmes sont en
compétition chez iga cm ice qui gère vos
données vous accumulez des points dans
différents commerces pharmacie stations
d'essence quincaillerie
c'est ce qu'on appelle un programme de
coalition qui ne permet pas d'obtenir
des offres personnalisées
ce que j'ai pensé devoir de donner un
métro qui lui permet de mieux suivre les
consommateurs puissent faire des offres
ciblées donc sont très bons pour donner
des repères sur place parce que donne
des exemples clients dans nos enquêtes
c'est que veulent avoir des rebelles
immédiatement métro et moi est un
programme privé
métro est propriétaire du programme est
de vous donner une des forces de métro
et moi en fait c'est le programme qui
est vue de mieux perçue au québec en
termes de personnalisation des offres
les consommateurs recherchent une valeur
ajoutée supérieure au fait d'avoir juste
des points comme y aura un vide et du
brouillard ou qui est beaucoup plus
avancé que des points cédés pour inclure
deux récompenses plus maintenant ça va
vers des événements magasin chez provigo
et maxi on utilise la carte pc optimum
qui sert aussi chez pharmaprix et s ou
c'est un programme de co édition privée
la carte la plus intéressante pour un
consommateur la catr optimum c'est que
vous pouvez sur le même cap gelé vos
achats d'épicerie pharmacie et sens ça
fidélise le consommateur d'aller à trois
endroits très précis et l'aujourd'hui
évidemment le concept en plus de
recevoir des points reçoit des
récompenses et reçoit des rabais sur
place elle apprend le pc optimum il ya
aucun point de base à l'épicerie qu'il
n'y a pas de points est mis sur votre
journal les dollars ht les points et
1000 sont uniquement sur vos offres
personnalisées si les cartes sont très
populaires les applications mobiles sont
plus utilisés chez les jeunes et encore
la bonne carte physique mais de plus en
plus aux envois vers les mobiles donc tu
passes par le mobile
les millions utilisent pas de carte
physique des fois en utilisant
l'application mobile on a plu davantage
que sont les dispos un exemple de
fidélisation qui fonctionne bien et
rejoint beaucoup de jeunes c'est celui
de starbucks avant d'arriver à chaleur
un café il arrive que les gens fait
payer tout ce qu'ils ont fait c'est le
ramasser
on parle ici d'un programme avec valeur
ajoutée mais dans les supermarchés les
consommateurs veulent avant tout des
rabais sur place les jeunes les
nouvelles technologies sont très attirés
mais quand vous dites les personnes de
30 à 50 ans et plus
évidemment sont attirés par les
programmes de fidélisation parce que
c'est des économies ici on regarde les
gens qui ont des revenus le mode s des
économies de 10 dollars beaucoup ont
notamment clientèle vieille saint pierre
est importante on met en pouvoir d'achat
le fait de savoir si une carte soins
la donnée à la 15 et ensuite recevoir un
chèque papier pour ensuite l'échangé il
faut que ce soit aussi facile que cette
notamment et qu'arrive t-il de vos
renseignements personnels au niveau du
commerce de détail et les données sont
bien protégés les programmes de
coalition n'est moins sûr chez métro et
provigo c'est différent parce que métro
examen reconnaissait la compétition dans
de la fermentation ou données privées
prêtre précieux points rabais gratuité
au final le consommateur aura toujours
le choix
[Musique]